this idea of these four year cycles  driven by bitcoins halving is over i  personally don't know where i stand on  that where do you stand on that yeah i  think it's over because the market is  much larger than it was and bitcoin is  not as dominant so at the margin the  four year cycle will have an impact but  not as large an impact for example the  eth 2.0 thing is going to create a  potential dynamic that's different i  think the cycles have changed you know  over time these very volatile trends get  less volatile and we saw that with  amazon in its early days it was like up  and down 95 percent then 65 percent and  then just gets less and less and less  because more people are in the network  show